pasa en las mejores familias
Este es el primer corte que sufrió David
sacks el presentador de la postulación
presidencial del republicano ron de
santis pero no fue el último
todo pasó en Twitter spaces y lo vivió
en primera persona su ceo y lo más uno
de los hombres más ricos del mundo
experimentando los mismos problemas que
el resto de los mortales
el esperado de Santi se acabó emergiendo
de las profundidades del internet
los internautas no perdonaron hashtags
en Twitter como error en el lanzamiento
estrellado y desastre En referencia a su
nombre una fiesta del Meme a la que se
sumó el expresidente Donald Trump
principal rival de The santis en las
primarias republicanas
incluso perdió un Twitter spaces con
presencia de Hitler o el
pero no solo Donald Trump el biff llegó
hasta el presidente Joe biden quien
podría enfrentarse a de santis siempre y
cuando este derrote a Trump y a su
Ingenio